now unfortunately accidents happen every
once in a while and on today's legal
minute eric palacio's from eric palacios
and associates the sponsors of this
segment tells us three things not to do
if you get into a car accident
hi i'm eric palacios welcome to this
week's legal minute the question for
this week is what are three things you
should not do after a car accident
number one
don't talk to the insurance company they
will record the call and later use it
against you number two don't let the tow
truck driver take you to an attorney you
don't know it's illegal for anyone to
approach you at the scene of an accident
and offer you legal services yet it
happens every day so don't let anyone
force you to go to a lawyer that you
don't know be sure to pick your own
attorney and number three don't wait to
call an attorney or seek medical
attention the longer you wait the harder
it is to prove that you were injured
during the accident insurance companies
will give you the run around for days
and sometimes weeks and then they will
ghost you stop communicating with you
and by then it's too late to set up a
proper claim
this has been the legal minute don't
forget to download my free app eric
palacio's legal app we'll see you next
week on the legal minute
and you can get more information by
going to eric palacios and associates
website
it is
ericklacioslaw.com or call that phone
number 702-444-7777
las vegas now